tastes green does that make any sense  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  hmm I like that one I got a good texture  to it they are a little bit nutty air  and a little bit creamier it's dense  it's fudgy just what you want in a  brownie you can definitely tell they're  not as sweet if somebody like Haneda  saundra party I don't have no clue I  don't really taste avocado I can just  tell something's up about as an  aftertaste of shrimp as a shrimpy  aftertaste I'm not kidding here  altogether I mean they're delicious  either way I think it's because you  mention it I taste this tastes like fish  now if you haven't said anything it just  tastes like the color green thank you  with these if I want no fear I mean it's  a damn Brandi how could you not love it  I say it tastes like it could possibly  have weed in it I've never had a weed  brownie but I assume teach nothing's  legally bound here